So, your Facebook page yes definitely dynamic. It's
built by Facebook servers and rendered in your browser.
The udacity.com logo, not dynamic. It doesn't change
very often it's just a file sitting on a
server. A blog's front page. Yes, definitely dynamic.
You know, a blog's front page probably takes all
of the blog's and resets somebody has written
and collates them together and renders a page that
you know, includes you know, the top ten or
whatever. And Google search results. Definitely dynamic. You run a
search, Google in the background you know, does a
search on, on all of their computers, puts together results
and then renders them for you on the fly.
So, these are all examples of dynamic content. You know,
content that's basically put together by programs. And, in this
class we're actually going to be building a blog, so that's
what you're going to to learn how to build.